außerirdisches leben könnte auf neu
entdeckten exo planeten gefunden werden
der laser der zukunft und autonome op
roboter das sind drei der fünf themen in
den klicks umtopfen jungs laser aus dem
tintenstrahldrucker der laser der
zukunftsforscher der école nationale
superieure der minen des örtchens haben
eine möglichkeit gefunden ein leser so
herzustellen dass dessen aktives medium
auch leser medium genannt nach gebrauch
einfach in den müll geworfen werden kann
das ist jetzt aber keine
umweltverschmutzung denn es handelt sich
um organischen müll
der fertige leser besteht wie jeder
herkömmliche leser aus der energiequelle
einem spiegel und dem aktiven medium das
aktive medium sorgt dafür dass die atome
oder moleküle in photonen gewandelt
werden
anders als bei den herkömmlichen lasern
setzt sich das aktive medium bei dem
neuen laser nicht aus kristallen
kohlenstoffdioxid oder farbstoff
lösungen zusammen das medium des lesers
der zukunft besteht aus organischer
tinte die ganz einfach mit einem
tintenstrahldrucker auf ein
trägermaterial gedruckt wird je nach
hinten kann man so auch die farbe des
lesers beeinflussen also dessen
wellenlängen ist das aktive medium nach
einiger zeit verbraucht kann es ganz
simpel und einfach ausgetauscht und das
alte recycelt werden
die herstellung dieser neuen laser chips
würden übrigens nur wenige cent kosten
die japanische raumfahrtbehörde jaxa
erklärt am 28 april die mission der
satellit promi für beendet was war
passiert jetzt ist es endlich klar zuvor
hatten wir berichtet der japanische
satellit to me ist möglicherweise
zerstört oder stark beschädigt worden
so war die meldung am zweiten april als
die bodenstation der raum verbürge einen
statusbericht anforderte reagierte der
satellit ende märz nicht er war im
februar vom weltraumbahnhof tanegashima
ins all transportiert worden und sollte
zum ersten mal seit 1999 wieder eine
möglichkeit darstellen aus dem all
röntgenstrahlung zu untersuchen
rund zwei monate nach dem start war sein
verbleib ungeklärt
tommy schien verschollen zu sein jetzt
konnte die ursache für das verschwinden
gefunden werden wie tommy sollte sich so
drehen dass die teleskop gerätschaften
auf die galaxie markarián 205 zeigen bei
dem ausrichten des teleskops versagte
jedoch die software
und gab den fehlerhaften status einer
ungewollten rotation durch
der röntgensatellit versetzte sich somit
automatisch in den safe mode und als er
sich selbst wie der reaktivierte
versuchte hitomi gegen die ungewollte
rotation vorzugehen ein weiterer
softwarefehler ließ dann aber auch noch
die düsen in die falsche richtung zünden
die die gerät damit total außer
kontrolle und wurde durch die
eintretenden fi kräfte zerstört der 273
millionen us-dollar teure satellit ist
nun verloren und konnte der wissenschaft
gerade mal drei tage lang dienen die
ursprünglich angesetzte mission dauer
war für zehn jahre angesetzt worden
roboter operiert vollkommen autonom der
op roboter smart ist robert kurz da
genannt ist ein neuer und
vielversprechender operation spot den
experten des children's national health
system in washington dc vor kurzem
vorgestellt haben star wurde in einem
vergleich menschlicher konkurrenz
gegenüber gestellt mit hilfe seines
optischen 3d tracking systems trat er
gegen einen chirurgen an beide sollten
einen schweine damen zu nennen die von
dem roboter durchgeführten op nahm zwar
etwas mehr zeit in anspruch zeichnete
sich aber durch eine höhere präzision
aus zitat wir demonstrieren dass eine
überwachte autonomie mit star nicht nur
machbar ist sondern in einigen aspekten
sogar die leistung herkömmlicher
chirurgie techniken übertreffen kann so
die wissenschaftler wichtig dazu zu
sagen ist dass die forscher die
menschlichen chirurgen in zukunft damit
nicht ersetzen sondern unterstützen
sollen zitat uns geht es keineswegs
darum die chirurgen zu ersetzen sondern
wir wollen die menschlichen
möglichkeiten und fähigkeiten erweitert
zitat ende fast komplett erblindeter
junge sieht seine mutter zum ersten mal
vor wenigen wochen haben wir euch in den
news ein video einer jungen frau gezeigt
die dank der wissenschaft das erste mal
die stimme ihres freundes und die ihrer
mutter hören konnte hier geht es um
einen jungen mann der seine mutter zum
ersten mal sieht wie bewegen
wissenschaft sein kann
außerirdisches leben könnte auf neu
entdeckten exo planeten gefunden werden
experten der universität lüttich haben
mit dem 60 zentimeter teleskop trapp ist
am la silla observatorium in chile drei
erdähnliche planeten entdeckt besonders
dabei ist vor allem dass diese in
kosmische reichweite um einen zwerg
stern liegen warum das so besonders ist
beschreibt michael jung von der
universität lüttich zitat der grund
hierfür ist einfach planetensysteme um
diese winzigen sterne sind die einzigen
orte an denen wir mit unserer heutigen
technologie leben auf einem erd- großen
exo planeten entdecken könnten
wenn wir also leben irgendwo im
universum finden wollen sollten wir
genau dort anfangen zu schauen gesagt
getan
in einer fernen von ungefähr 40
lichtjahre fanden sie ein drei sterne
system um den zwerg stern trapp ist eins
alle drei planeten sollen ungefähr so
groß sein wie die erde und
lebensfreundliche habitablen zonen
besitzen wenn die forscher diese
vermutung tatsächlich bestätigen können
wäre das eine sensation zitat noch
innerhalb unserer generation werden wir
herausfinden ob diese planeten bewohnt
sind das ist ein echter jackpot für
unser fachgebiet so julien de witt vom
in schon rund zwei jahren sollen andere
teleskope zur unterstützung eingesetzt
werden um dann vielleicht die alte frage
zu klären ob da draußen noch anderes
leben existiert und so seine frage
würdet ihr euch eigentlich lieber von
einem roboter oder von einem chirurgen
operieren lassen
ich bin auf eure meinung dazu gespannt
wenn euch das video gefallen hat dann
einen daumen